pour ursula von der leyen la présidente
de la commission européenne la mission
de l'union européenne est d'assurer un
avenir numérique qui soit le reflet du
meilleur de l'europe ouvert aux nets
divers démocratique et sur un voeu pieux
certes mais sur le papier on est loin de
ces belles promesses en réalité c'est
plutôt une terrible bataille d'influencé
que livre à bruxelles les géants du net
google amazon facebook microsoft qu'on
appelle les gars femme un rapport publié
par les ong lobby control et ceo dévoile
les moyens colossaux mise en oeuvre pour
aiguiller la politique numérique de
l'union européenne en faveur des gars
femmes selon le rapport 612 entreprises
groupes et associations ont dépensé plus
de 97 millions d'euros cette année et 10
entreprises assument ce budget d'un
tiers regarde à ce classement google
arrive en première position des dépenses
de lobbying avec
5,75 millions d'euros en deuxième mari
facebook avec 5,5 millions d'euros puis
microsoft avec 5,25 millions apple avec
3,5 millions et huawei arrive en
cinquième position suivie d'amazon avec
2,75 millions d'euros il faut savoir que
20 % de ces entreprises pro lobbying à
bruxelles sont basés aux états unis mais
ont des attaches très solide en europe
selon le rapport l'argent déboursé sert
à rémunérer des consultants des cabinets
d'avocats et des think tanks y
parviennent à s'immiscer dans les
réunions déjeuner et séminaire organisé
par la commission européenne
leur rôle est également d'entretenir
l'image de ces entreprises avec des
communications orienté vers la société
civile et même vers certains partis
politiques il y a en outre tout un
réseau de think tanks et de boîtes de
consultants qui sont en partie financés
par ces big tech et qui sert leurs
intérêts à bruxelles je me souviens du
nombre indécent de déjeuner séminaires
et autres conférences organisées
quotidiennement par ces grands groupes
ou des boîtes de consultants travaillant
pour eux elles selon le rapport depuis
décembre 2019 les lobbyistes de google
ont obtenu par moins de quarante six
réunions avec la commission vander jene
facebook et microsoft en ont décroché 40
tandis qu amazon en a eu 20 appels et
huawei ont eu droit à 14 meetings ces
lobbies sont clairement actif et ne
perdent pas leur temps est d'après l'anc
est l'objectif ultime des cas femme
n'est pas forcément d'empêcher les
régulations mais plutôt de s'assurer une
marge de manoeuvre est de ralentir les
processus pour préserver leur modèle
économique
il cherche à ralentir l'adoption des
réformes ou milite pour que les textes
soit écrit de telle manière qu'il est
plus facile pour eux ensuite de
contourner les mesures adoptées de
réformes at ease particulièrement leurs
craintes la législation sur le marché
numérique sans s'est elle assurée une
libre concurrence entre tous les acteurs
du numérique et la législation sur les
services numériques qui visent à réguler
les contenus sensibles échangées est
telle que la haine en ligne et la
désinformation sur les réseaux sociaux
alors qu un arsenal législatif se
préparer contre google le géant du net
concocté en coulisses en représailles
une campagne agressive contre le
commissaire européen thierry breton une
information avérée après la fuite d'un
document en interne finalement le pdg de
google s'est alors excusé et a déclaré
qu internet ne doit pas demeurer un far
west les gars femmes pèse lourd et leur
influence est sans équivoque grisés par
leur propre puissance les mastodontes du
web ne sont pas prêts à renoncer à leur
position dominante et il faudra aux
fonctionnaires européens une volonté
politique inébranlable pour les y
contraindre